[Music]
these are velcros
i don't have to tie my shoes
i don't have to tie my shoes i rock my
favorite shoe brand and i just
that's the noise it makes
[Music]
hey it's your boy david lucas man i'm
out here at the bread improv with my dog
brendan's shop you know we got the dick
boy we all think you see and we fly man
i think we got to sold out overnight man
y'all make sure y'all check us out on
tour all right
[Music]
yes sir you know what what what up what
are you ready
[Music]
getting ready to go up after david lucas
he out there
crushing it killing it
[Music]
[Applause]
the first show was dope dog you know
what i'm saying we're out here in brea
oc you know they've been i like i like
they're so tight though for david
because david comes with
the heat so they just got off work and
then david's
you know
blender yeah i i was i was definitely
you know they're tight dave gets them on
tight
what's up
[Music]
late show
goddammit got white in here little
[ __ ] wonder wall you know
backflips and [ __ ] you guys go crazy
it's the thickest cheerleader i've ever
seen
that backflip was like yeah
me too man it also be hilarious if he
snapped his neck anyway
just kidding chappelle love you
if you cut chappelle's veins blink when
they do pours out
it's good to see you guys man
[Music]
[Applause]
he said that man's lips look like
michelin tired
that's a good roast joke
that is a great roast joke
like i might use that they call it
goodell [ __ ]
yeah that's that's what got him fired
that's what got him yeah and i like how
that feels like we didn't see any other
compromising emails from any other teams
thank you
didn't they say this really what two
hundred thousand emails something crazy
like crazy yeah grew them bro yeah is
the other one talking like that
he can't beat them
similar to what you were saying yeah
locker room talk and yeah like it's fake
yeah that that type of stuff like dog we
could be canceled
is this the room
[Music]
let's go big boy baby
yo that [ __ ] was awesome let me tell you
chappelle's ass is [ __ ] fat as [ __ ]
you need to see that [ __ ] in person and
[ __ ] brandon is thicker than ever in
person you need to come see this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] was [ __ ] funny as hell i
love it i love all of it
all right so we've been doing this with
everybody uh we're doing a [ __ ] marry
kill so the [ __ ] marry kill we're gonna
do it's going to be stevie weeby
eric griffin and chin
okay so i would probably [ __ ] stevie
because it'd probably be fun
i would have to probably kill chin
because i mean i'm sorry chin i love you
but you're not my type but eric griffin
that's that's like wifey right there
that fool i don't know he'll make me
feel so comfortable maybe cook for me
you know i don't know post you every
morning post me every morning i feel
comfortable he wouldn't cheat on me he
said it before you know he takes video
games to his house like every hotel he's
at he wouldn't [ __ ] [ __ ] anymore so
yeah definitely that's my answer right
there so
why are you out here tonight um
her boyfriend which is my brother-in-law
bought tickets for my fiancee's birthday
okay nice do you guys know a lot of
comedians are you guys like into comedy
at all besides outside brandon like big
names i would say athletes for me i
don't know yeah
so uh listed a couple of big names for
like jokoy chancey handler
um dave chappelle
yeah okay all right so the last game
we're gonna play if you guys are okay
with it is [ __ ] marry kale um
tonight we've been doing it with the
lineup obviously since you guys aren't
too familiar with it
yeah yeah we can do that um okay all
right so the first person that we're
gonna say is chappelle
uh he's i'll give you a little
background he's from arizona he's a
world champion cheerleader uh turned
comic here he is
okay okay so that's chappelle the next
conte uh person we have is david lucas
he's one of the openers tonight as well
okay
and then lastly
do you guys know what brendan looks like
yeah so [ __ ] marry kill david chappelle
or brandon
we don't get any backstory what was it
so
david lucas uh he's from texas he works
with uh tony hinchcliffe he's a
professional roaster very great comic uh
and then brennan uh he's a former top 10
heavyweight in the ufc and now he's
getting into comedy he's doing pretty
[ __ ] solid at it so uh yeah
okay i would marry chappelle because i
used to cheerlead as well in what a
connection oh yeah um
i would [ __ ] brendon shop and i feel
very bad but i don't know the last man
so i guess that leaves yeah killing to
him unfortunately fair enough you did
the same thing okay
i didn't like him i liked his comedy so
all right so what'd you enjoy most about
the show tonight you know what chappelle
is hilarious as [ __ ] okay chappelle and
brennan it's
they're different
like it's funny because it's different
from the podcast but it's just it's
hilarious i'm gonna ask you a [ __ ] merry
kill oh [ __ ] uh so we're going to go
with david lucas
brendan
oh damn i don't like to think he's like
him i don't like thickies like him just
two things you got it you gotta show the
thick women and thick men love that's
all that's a thick boy brand they should
be thick
thick people don't get they don't get
nothing
i'm pretty good
hey chappelle i'm catching up to spell
right here
so all right so david lucas kill the
next two are justin elliott and brandon
chob where do you go
agree with that yeah david lucas will
def definitely a bear definitely a bear
no uh i watch everything i um
king of the sting uh below the bell
everything man i've been honest in the
beginning um i might saw it from maybe
like joe rogan i think it was the first
time his podcasts were so long i was
like dude let me find some you know a
little bit thing but um yeah i know i
watch all the everything everything okay
and what about you same thing like i'll
be honest like he showed me the podcast
and everything so i'm just like
i'm just going to ask you one more
question it's going to be a [ __ ] marry
kill
and uh it's going to be
between
we'll do
chin
chapelle
and brenden
i know i hear about his stories
i don't know we might have to kill him
because i don't know you could be safe
with him
he seems like he'd be able to take care
of you never under he never tells us
what he's talking about with him and his
friends loving each other so it's kind
of scary like you know and he likes
ketamine
um
i'm not i mean i'll probably marry
chappelle because i know he's not going
to want to tell nobody what's going on
wow yeah yeah and brandon will's other
options [ __ ] marry kale so
chappelle okay
maybe chin chin will actually probably
be [ __ ] i gotta kill brendan oh wow
yeah maybe maybe switching around wow
yeah that's the first one we got tonight
hear that brendan
are you told i'm in there i was like dog
we can go right now i got i brought
another little short king short prince
oh yeah sure king nation we've been
doing it with everyone all night we're
playing [ __ ] marry kill
so we're gonna do
brendan
brian and chin
[ __ ] marry kill okay so
i'm gonna
i'm gonna care i'm gonna kill chin
sorry chin sorry chin uh
i'm gonna
[ __ ] brennan and i'm gonna marry
kellen
now
can i ask you your reasoning behind like
[ __ ] brandon and marrying uh brian uh
i think i think brandon's like a
one-and-done
like
cullen's in for the long run i think
chen's just kind of yeah do you think do
you think callum would be a good like
husband like do you think he'd be a good
house husband yeah i think a bigger
house hasn't been who do you think would
make a better house husband ryan cowan
or eric griffin oh man i think it's
still colin really yeah i think so
colin's not proposing to you every
morning like eric is to his girl though
but i think he's just he has that warm
touch
all right fair enough what's up guys
that's a wrap on bread great weekend
with my favorite club shout out to mikey
and brittany literally one of my
favorite clubs we had such a good time
we're tightening up the set we're tied
up with set because we have something
very special for dallas november 11th to
the 13th aston improv tickets are almost
freaking sold out that's texas for you
we're going to have one special last
night a special 30 come in hot that's it
man like subscribe smash that button as
the kids say that's it stay fit
[Music]